major news overnight last night and
overnight on a number of fronts let's
get caught up on everything that's going
on first and foremost US officials have
now told numerous media outlets
including CNN that the FBI has
information indicating that Associates
of Donald Trump did indeed communicate
with suspected Russian operatives to
possibly coordinate the release of
information damaging to Hillary
Clinton's presidential campaign the FBI
is again according to US officials
reviewing that information which
includes a combination of human
intelligence travel records phone
records and business records there's one
law enforcement official who said that
the information in hand suggests quote
people connected to the campaign were in
contact and it appeared that they were
giving the thumbs-up to release
information when it was ready there are
other US officials who spoke to CNN for
example saying it is yet premature to
draw that specific and inference from
the information gathered so far since it
is largely circumstantial although not
everybody agrees that this is
circumstantial I will tell you more
about that in a moment it's all starting
to fall off the wall folks the White
House didn't comment the FBI declined to
comment on this specifically so far but
in addition to these revelations we now
have Democratic congressman Adam Schiff
the ranking member of the House
Intelligence Committee the committee
looking will this is one of the places
where there's an investigation going on
into Trump Russia the FBI is another
place Adam Schiff the ranking member of
the House in telemedicine that the case
for the Trump Russia collusion is now
more than circumstantial this is huge
this is a ranking member of the
committee that's investigating this and
receiving the information on a day to
day basis and I want to be super clear
here since everything sort of becomes
background noise in the era of trumpet
as its scandal after scandal Adam Schiff
who is privy to the information being
reviewed says there is now a case that
is beyond sir
stan shil with regard to collusion and
coordination of Trump in Russia here he
is
I think you admit it's a circum all you
have right now is a circumstantial case
actually no Chuck I can tell you that
the case is more than that
and I can't go into the particulars but
there is more than circumstantial
evidence now so again I think you had
fine direct evidence of collusion I
don't want to go into specifics but I
will say that there is evidence that is
not circumstantial and and is very much
worthy of investigation so that is what
we ought to do now again I think we have
been dealt a serious body blow to the
credibility of our ability to get
answers by today's events so what did he
mean there Delta body blow by today's
events that relates to Republican Devin
Nunez and I'll get to that next but this
is on the way to an explosion isn't it
PAC right it seems like the writers keep
drawing this one out it's like every
single week there's another link in the
chain here and they keep leaving us on
cliffhangers I mean yes this is the guy
who's the ranking member of the House
Intelligence Committee but he's also a
Democrat these are just words so we'll
see what evidence they come out with but
as of now I mean it looks like the
writing's on the wall
and what people seem to miss there's
still a contingent of people that email
me and they say David there is no Russia
story period I don't know I mean if
you've not been paying attention to the
news for the last six months maybe that
would explain thinking that there is no
Russia story but we never see a
backtrack every time we learn something
new the process is it's denied by Trump
and then slowly we verify that at least
some aspects of it are indeed true and
there's been no big moment at where the
drive towards confirming collusion
between Trump and Russia has been put in
reverse there's been no big moment where
we say oh you know what the building
stories of the last two months we were
wrong about all of that we just keep
putting what's drip drip drip there are
plenty of things from the Trump Rasha
dossier that haven't been confirmed yet
from what we've seen everything that's
important to the investigation not
things like the more salacious
the Pat is mentioning that we've not
proven that Donald Trump has a urine
fetish that doesn't tell us that the
broader story of Trump Russia collusion
has been backtracked
in any way whatsoever we are heading
towards an explosion now let me get to
what did what did Adam Schiff mean by
Delta body blow by today's event that
relates to the head of the house Intel
committee Devin Nunez and that is what I
want to talk about next